Well hello there!
Sorry, I was just busy respecting women.
My name is "nice guy PewDiePie", and I've collected millions of followers, just like yourself who are
just that - nice guys. We spend most of our days respecting whamen and putting them first.
Just that, nice guys.
We spend most of our days respecting women and putting them first
Thinking, "How can we be better? How can we be less horrible demons, creatures of the night?"
Join me!
As we will now.. G0-gO-G-g00
Go through some of the nicest guys on the internet
Just like me, and just like you.
Or at least if you're not yet...
u could become a nice guy
Let's check out the "nice guy" subreddit....
And celebrate..some of the nicest people on the planet
Nice Guys
"Operator: what is your emergency?"
"Please help, some men broke into my home."
"Not all men are like that. I wouldn't do that."
*laugh*
As a fellow nice guy myself, I would never break into another wahmen's home
If there was a man in there perhaps, I would consider it...
...but I would make sure the woman was feeling safe.
Cuz I'm a nice guy Pewdiepie,
and if you were a nice guy as well, you would understand.
"I hate the friend zone
You make a girl chocolate milk, and she won't have some fun
sex with you.
"Unbelievable, what's the point?"
*laugh*
I made this bitch
Chocolate! I gave you my everything
I'm making chocolate milk!!! Why don't you love me?
I'M SUCH A NICE GUY!!!
[Tommy-san] "Why Lisa, why Lisa? Please TALK to me, PLEASE!"
Why do all these women pick all these douche bags?
If they only knew...
What a nice guy I am!
Bitches would be all over me!
[Lisa] You're scaring me.
"Graffiti I saw in Melbourne today."
"How nice guys think sex works."
"Times are respected women." This is @Lushsux
Come on at least credit
Credit the man properly!
"We look so much like a couple here. Ha ha ha, ha ha. A couple of BESTIES!"
Oh nooo. Everyone, a moment of silence for this man
That's gonna, that's gonna fuckin sting. You know everyone's
gonna see that be like god damn that bitch got cucked the fuck out, man.
"Me:
I'd like to become a citizen of Finland."
"Oh, nice!"
"Uh, I guess."
"Back of line."
"Why?"
"Nice guys FINNISH last."
*clapping* Good job
Hey, hey, how about this one, "Hey are you Finnish? No, I am Swedish!!
*clapping*
Ahh!
"Yes, I am proud virgin."
"Because unlike you,"
"sexually activated SAVAGES,"
"I actually respect women!"
Ugh.
I would never ever
Put ANY genitals anywhere near you!
It's a shame with those dick sucking lips, too. You had a lot of potential
"Sigh, I wish some girl could see past my looks and"
"Just like me for who I am."
"I love you Robert." "Yes, but you're ugly"
*laugh*
It's always like... nice guys is always just guys going for girls out of their league. I think that's the issue I mean NO!
They are nice guys because in their heart they have good intention, okay?
They're not some sexually charged
SAVAGES.
"Mario you saved me, to thank you here is a kiss!"
"I crossed eight worlds full of monsters my princess. Take off your pan-"
I actually said this when I played the latest Super Mario cuz you do so much shit to save her right? I'm like, she better
Bish better put out
Probably shouldn't add that in.
Ha...!
What are they supposed to mean?!
My god. "I'm not your average nice guy, cuz I can give you orgasm
You'll never forget!"
"Doubt it."
"I don't lie to women... lol."
"So you only lie to men?"
OH!
"I don't believe in
antiquated concept of dating,
Relationship and married." "After seeing your profile, I have changed my mind~."
Good thing - yeah, what a great coincidence! He changed his mind right after he got rejected. That's good!
They worked out great for everyone!
"Hello. I'm Stan, nice to meet you.
You're so attractive to me, and I love your cute face."
20 minutes later...
"STUCK UP BITCH. I COULD BEAT THE LIVING SHIT OUT OF YOU-
You made me wait twenty minutes? Arrgh!!
I may be a nice guy...
I may be a nice guy named Stan, but if you make me wait twenty minutes,
Then my fury will be unleashed upon on you, you stuck up B WORD.
"It's stupid when girls say they can't find a guy yet, they ignore me."
"It's like saying you're hungry when there's a hot dog on the ground."
*laugh*
That's a good tweet.
"Why would anyone drink or do drugs I get high off respecting women." Me too and anyone
That's a nice guy can relate. It's one of the most joyous
adventures you can go on. It's very rewarding.
"I have a boyfriend that's nice, but I'm not interested, sorry."
"You are as every girl...
...ugly."
"No need to be rude."
"Why me? You are rude. No me."
"How am I rude?"
"Every girls are the same."
"How come?"
"You all lie, cheat, not give me.."
"Okay, what the fuck?"
"A good guy... a chance."
I feel for this man. You gotta give the good man a chance! A good guy deserves his chance!
"I already have a boyfriend."
"I hope he cheat on you. You deser-be that. You ugly."
"Hope you die" *laugh*
Okay, now. Goodbye. Hope you die.
"I think men should post 'Not Me' to show that most of us are good men who would never assault or abuse women..."
"Yet, we love and honor them!"
Yes. #NotMe
Someone actually thought this. Oh my god. #NotMe. Not me. I'm a nice guy
"Hey Anna"
"Was there English homework?"
"Nope."
"Thank you so much!"
"No problem, dude"
"So what's up?"
"Filling out college applications."
"Cool, I'm watching the flash... you there?"
"Yeah, sorry. I was focused on my work."
"Can we talk about something?"
"Okay dude."
"Do you even want to talk?"
"I can talk."
"Let's talk about movies. What's your favorite movie?"
[Man on phone] Do you like scary movies?
[Woman] Uh huh.
[Man on phone] What's your favorite scary movie?
"Let me think... I like Guardians of the Galaxy"
"If I didn't know better. I think you were trying to impress me."
"What?"
"Everyone knows I love superheroes."
"Lots of people like them."
"Well, it's cool that we have this in common. We actually are pretty similar if you think about it."
"Are you mad at me?"
"No, why would I be mad at you?"
"Oh, well you didn't respond, so I just assumed. I'm sorry"
"Nah, it's all good. I'm just swamped right now."
"Well when you aren't busy...
...would you like to go on a date with me? I'll treat you to a nice dinner take you to a movie."
"Not sure how much
the boyfriend would like that."
"Well, you don't have to be so rude about it."
*laughs*
[Woman] What do you want?!
[Man] To see what your insides look like.
"You've been short with me this entire conversation!! *yells in swedish nice guy*"
Oh my god...!
I can't Jesus Christ. It's tough being a nice guy. We got a - we got a short fuse.
"I rspected wahmen three times today. Lemme smash."
"That's not how it works."
YES IT IS!
YES IT IS!!
Oh!
"Irma is a cute name. Maybe if I stay..
"..She'll see my dedication to her and and will go out with me."
"The hurricane?"
"My boyfriend, what a jerk."
"M'lady surely deserves better! I would always treat you with utmost respect!"
"Wow, you are the nicest man I've ever met."
"In fact, TOO NICE!"
"NOOOOOOOO!"
*laughs*
Damn me and my niceness!
ARGH! CURSE ME!
I am just not allowed to love...
For I am just too nice.
"What were you bullied for?"
"For being shy and uncomfortable around boys."
ATATATATA
tatataaa!
How can I make this about me?
Let's see!
"I agree. Us men can be literal assholes, but-"
But!
Gotta add in that - I'm not an asshole
"There are some lovely and generous gentlemen like ME...
...out there...
...Somewhere!"
If you're an actual nice person, you shouldn't have to try so hard to let everyone else know that you're a nice person,
You should just be a nice person.
Just like MEEEE!
Leave a like if you're a nice guy. No matter who you are, if you're a nice guy
This has been your host, nice guy Pewdiepie. Now, excuse me while I keep on respecting wahmen.
Everyday, bro.
Squad Fam Out™
[Man on phone] You like scary movies?
[Woman] Uh huh.
[Man on phone] What's your favorite scary movie?
*peaceful music*